cartoons are no longer just for kids
with progressive characters and
intriguing story lines these the
cartoons parents will love watching to
stay tuned to see one of the craziest
shows ever winning over the hearts of
kids and adults at the same time if
you're new here hit that subscribe
button to never miss another video and
don't forget to give us the big thumbs
up let's check out ten kids cartoons
parents will love watching too Steven
universe Steven universe might be one of
the weirdest shows ever but that's
what's so great about it and if you
haven't seen it there's a good chance
you'll appreciate it as an adult while
there are definitely elements of this
show kids can enjoy the adults will
appreciate hidden innuendos and just
general adult humor that often goes over
children's heads but Steven universe
also focuses on some of the life lessons
kids don't tend to get from other
cartoons the show follows Steve and
crystal gems but the story behind those
is quite complicated gems were
originally brought on the earth
thousands of years ago to colonize it
but a small group rebelled and became
the Earth's protectors one of those gems
was Stephens mother who gave up her
physical form so she could be born
Stephens been living with crystal gems
ever since the show has its wacky
moments but it also touches on some of
the most interesting subjects characters
like amethyst will make you giggle while
the adventures will keep you entertained
at all times the show also touches on
things like self-care getting out your
feelings through meditation breaking
stereotypes and gender roles letting go
and moving on and many more life lessons
that would be beneficial for kids as
well as adults SpongeBob SquarePants
everyone's heard of SpongeBob
SquarePants and most adults have a
love-hate relationship with the show
it's hard to believe it could be
enjoyable but after a while you kind of
get into its spirit and accept this
crazy cartoon SpongeBob SquarePants is
all about the underwater world called
bikini bottom we follow the crazy lives
of spongebob his starfish friend Patrick
and other characters like mr. Krabs
plankton Gary and so on the characters
often get themselves in trouble but what
makes this show so great is the
underrated humor of the show the sarcasm
and often hidden references would be
appreciated by plenty of adults who will
probably identify with mr. Krabs and
Squidward more than with any other
characters
of course the show also makes us ask
existential questions like how come it's
based underwater when the characters
also swim in a swimming pool
overall SpongeBob SquarePants is for
those looking for a little bit of guilty
pleasure fun and a reminder that it's
okay to giggle at whacky things even as
an adult although it's hard to believe
the show could come with life lessons
there are definitely lessons that can be
found through various moments and
storylines we have a feeling many adults
do enjoy spongebob and if that's you
make sure to let us know Adventure Time
Adventure Time might look like a cartoon
about a boy and his dog but it's so much
more than that the dog's name is Jake
and he can actually morph in pretty much
any shape and size they live in the
post-apocalyptic time and the story
revolves around the characters going on
adventures Adventure Time has universal
entertainment value that will appeal to
both kids and adults besides some
episodes get really crazy so an adult
has to be present to even try to explain
what's going on in the scenes Adventure
time also gives a unique perspective on
a number of issues some parents might
not know how to talk about with to their
children and it even touches on mental
health and depression the show also
teaches kids that making mistakes is
just a part of growing up and that life
can easily get scary and dark parents
will probably be able to find a deeper
meaning in the small quotes the
characters make throughout the show
these quotes include asking what's the
point of living if you get everything
the minute you want it and doing things
from your heart although it might seem
that Adventure Time is just a bizarre
show with a morphing dog it's actually
so much more than that and we think that
adult fans of the show can definitely
agree Avatar The Last Airbender
Avatar The Last Airbender might possibly
attract more adults than it does kids
the show focuses on a 12 year old avatar
that goes by the name Aang who realizes
he can control the elements of air water
earth and Fire these elements were on
the verge of destruction after the Fire
Nation declared war but Aang is the one
who joins forces with the other
characters on the show and helps restore
balance and harmony to their world
it sounds pretty awesome to be able to
manipulate air water earth and fire
right the what sets this show apart from
others is that it expresses feminism the
characters often don't agree with gender
stereotyping and many of the male care
learn about the importance of gender
equality you can find a range of diverse
female characters and a representation
from every part of life and the best
part is the male characters respect that
each character also comes with a flaw
that adds even more complexity to the
series if you love three-dimensional
characters that come with layers of
personality and backstory
you'll love this cartoon the show also
focuses on Chinese martial arts and
traditional Asian culture it's by far
one of Dubey's problematic cartoons out
there which is exactly why we love it
and don't even bother watching the same
name to movie because the cartoon is a
million times better
hey Arnold most of adults remember
watching hey Arnold as kids but this
show is also still totally watchable
even if you're an adult
hey Arnold is all about the
nine-year-old Arnold who lives with his
totally wacky grandparents that really
know how to spice up this show Arnold is
a good kid and throughout the show he
helps people solve problems or dives
into adventures of his own but what hey
Arnold does best is highlight the fact
that there's no universal rule to being
normal and you should always be yourself
the show also highlights the importance
of trusting yourself and have confidence
in what you do no matter where you come
from Hey Arnold also focuses on
beautiful friendships the show's
characters are absolutely hilarious but
what's even better is the fact that the
characters are truly diverse it also
focuses on showing the difference in
functionalities between families and
households for example many kids might
not realize the fact that Helga's
parents were practically never there and
her character is a result of negligence
and poor parents will care Hey Arnold
has an important life lesson at the end
of every episode which is something that
doesn't happen in a lot of 1-dimensional
cartoons if you're looking for a
nostalgic show you should definitely
give hey Arnold a chance as many of its
storylines are still relevant in today's
world Teen Titans go one of our favorite
shows ever has to be Teen Titans go
while many prefer the original Teen
Titans a lot of kids still watch the
miniature version of the show Teen
Titans go is all about following the
adventures of much younger versions of
Teen Titans
include characters like Beast Boy Robin
Starfire Raven and many others even some
of your favorite superheroes make an
appearance these characters often go on
various adventures but what sticks this
show apart from others is its sense of
humor characters like Raven will
definitely make you giggle with their
sarcasm that probably went over a lot of
kids heads each character is completely
unique and has an entirely different
point of view on the same issue which
creates a fantastic dialogue and
never-ending playful exchanges and
remarks if you love DC Universe you'll
also find plenty of references to other
shows from inside jokes about DC
Universe to making fun of the show
itself Teen Titans go creatively uses
its sense of humor and it definitely
works apart from that the show
storylines also focus on some of the
cases many kids and adults might face in
their life of course the show is full of
having an easy sense of humor but we
have a feeling a lot of adults will
appreciate Teen Titans go regular show
regular show has been around for quite a
while and aired until January 2017 which
is why it deserves its spot on our list
the cartoon is all about the daily lives
of two 23 year old animal friends who
might be the only main cartoon
characters that are adults Mordecai and
Rigby are lazy groundskeepers at a park
who do anything else but try to work the
show gives kids an interesting insight
into what life at work might look like
the characters might be slightly
stereotypical but what makes this show
so good is its unique brand of humor
that will be appreciated by kids and
adults the characters are absolutely
hilarious and storylines are full of
lessons
although Mordecai and Rigby are
basically animals we feel like this show
will resonate with any adult who's
looking for a reminder that life really
isn't that serious the show might get
slightly inappropriate at times which is
exactly why we think this ins of humor
might be more appreciated by adults
rather than children even though plenty
of kids still watch this show
besides adults we'll definitely be able
to identify with Mordecai and Rigby at
their workplace because a lot of us want
to do exactly the same thing it's a
wacky show with plenty of heartfelt and
iconic moments you'll love to watch Tom
and Jerry speaking of wacky shows Tom
and Jerry is one of those cartoons you
just can't help but watch even if you're
an adult whether it's a part of
nostalgia or actual quality show
and Gerry is one of those shows that can
be watched by absolutely all ages and it
doesn't even have to be a guilty
pleasure cartoon the show even made a
comeback in 2014 after its consistent
popularity it's one of the most iconic
shows ever even though almost every
episode to feature the exact same story
the cat chases the mouse the mouse
outwits him and the two somehow end up
getting along at some point it's a
light-hearted show that's easy to watch
and won't go over a lot of people's
heads but it's one of those cartoons
every parent should watch with their
child and introduce them to a show they
used to watch as kids and even though it
doesn't feature diverse characters
stunning animations or a complex
dialogue it'll bring plenty of cartoon
nostalgia in every adults lives funny
enough the show still gets analyzed
today it was reported that there are a
lot of concerning health and safety
hazards made in this cartoon but all
nineties kids who are now adults will
still be able to giggle at Tom and
Jerry's crazy adventures Kim Possible
and now let's move on to one of our
favorite shows for adults we've all
probably seen at least one episode of
Kim Possible the show focuses on a
teenager called Kim Possible who's just
an everyday child even though she fights
a crime on a regular basis she even has
a best friend who's her sidekick
the show's sense of humor is very
progressive and we guarantee you'll be
able to laugh in every single episode
one of the best benefits of this show is
focusing on girl power the main
character of the show might be a
cheerleader but she's still able to kick
some butt when she needs to
besides team possible also shows us the
beauty of true friendship and reminds us
that there are still good people out
there in this world alongside the show
also highlights the importance of family
and self-confidence that you should
never let anything hold you back the
cartoon also bravely fights against
gender stereotypes and gives everyone a
unique power and contribution to the
storyline Kim's own slogan is that she
can do anything
which should definitely be a lesson for
all kids and adults watching the show if
you're looking for a new show that
focuses on never giving up and fighting
through everything life throws your way
Kim Possible is the one you should watch
gravity falls
we love gravity falls on our channel and
we really think it's the best cartoon
for adults while many kids still watch
this show it brings a completely
different viewpoint to adults gravity
falls focuses on a 12 year
dipper pines and his twin sister Mabel
who live in a town where crazy things
tend to happen when dipper finds a
mysterious journal in the forest he
starts exploring the mysteries of the
gravity falls town the characters of the
show are some of the most complex and
unusual characters she will ever meet
but without them this cartoon wouldn't
be the same we're also taught that it's
okay to be who you are even if people
don't agree with your personality or
your clothes you'll be able to find
plenty of pop-culture references but
what's even better is the fact that the
show also throws in plenty of Easter
eggs for you dipper and Mabel's days are
always filled with unpredictable
adventures that will make everyone laugh
some episodes are definitely more
suitable for adults and many kids will
never be able to understand some of the
old school references made by the show
the adult sense of humor is definitely
what sets this show apart from any other
cartoon we mentioned today if you're an
adult make sure to let us know what's
your favorite cartoon that's it for our
video don't forget to subscribe to our
channel and hit that like button for
more videos like this one see you next
time
[Music]